you
fire the bad [ __ ] that's what
I'm smoking from perennial fire
[ __ ] og you kidding me or what
Saturday night I'm chillaxing the
stitches around I got a little blood
coming out of my nose from time to time
but you know how we do it by this time
I'm used to [ __ ] anything I had tubes
in my [ __ ] nose yeah it's over today
I took a little nap at the antibiotics
that boy yogurt you know how we do it
you gotta put the [ __ ] dumb I will be
back in the stomach so you take little
shits and whatnot you understand me
uncle Joey here puff them before EBI on
fight pass I don't know what it's gonna
cost you another [ __ ] it is it worth it
Eddie Bravo's down there jumping up and
down booth buffer [ __ ] announcing
tonight it's a tremendous [ __ ] show
don't forget EBI but Joey enough with
the chili chatter we don't give a [ __ ]
about digital we wanna we want to see
the smoke of life enough is enough
that's a doctor beliefs buff right there
you have his damn it we got [ __ ] fire
and we put Bowler wedding cake oh [ __ ] a
beautiful [ __ ] sativa hybrid
throw any like [ __ ] Roger Clemens and
[ __ ] it 95 understand me anyway I've
been smoking dope since what maybe six
thirty in the end still recuperating
from the liquid said last night didn't
hit me as much sleep I'd have to take my
shoes off I was the sweat profusely it's
like that came home that's some super
look asleep
listen it's been a hard life uncle Joey
look at the map on his [ __ ] face you
got said you got [ __ ] H you got some
good fruits you got some different
totals it don't bother me no those are C
cons again you from the [ __ ] doctor
you let it affect the town or hit me
better the [ __ ] oxy cats
the [ __ ] it Saturday night were in or
relaxing maybe you're going out it's
still early
what is it on these ghost [ __ ] 10
o'clock you can still wash your [ __ ]
get out then get somebody [ __ ] [ __ ] on
your eyeballs understand me or whatever
the [ __ ] you're into I mean it's
Saturday night you turn into a [ __ ]
what you go bananas you're supposed to
do mine man yeah any of the judge either
help me I used to lose my mind them
[ __ ] savage right story in life
no-parole Bluebook crawling on the floor
pilot to Bombardier and putting sheet
rock in my [ __ ] nose eh it happens
but enough is enough choice miss triumph
is [ __ ] a wedding cake I hit it
earlier this shit's strong and the
[ __ ] then the blue cookies I got some
little cookies - you know me though no
if it's good I purchased that's it Bona
grant man
that's right ring that time to be [ __ ]
around a weed that tastes good or yeah
you know these [ __ ] mobiles I got
hardly went back it was a body hi okay
yeah good let me hit you with a [ __ ]
with a body [ __ ] tanked or something
yeah well leave me the [ __ ] alone please
I'm over hit you never seen a [ __ ]
that will never hit me with a body I
like I need that my [ __ ] life
unbelievable you got to put up with yeah
I'm with Gentiles I'm surrounded anyway
well what else is gonna try this [ __ ]
up wedding cake with a something that's
[ __ ] fire you will see the [ __ ]
tempers and as my first ball of it
listen I went to the week's go by 1002
this morning
it opens at 10:00 I'm the first one that
I'll [ __ ] around I'm gonna see nobody
wanna [ __ ] me over
I don't give a [ __ ] up too jealous of me
we don't know what we don't want when I
go in there I get home I sit in front of
my house I put the [ __ ] thing in a
bag open up the subtle rules but I
believe the window closes look just gets
the [ __ ] in the car and I melt that
[ __ ] wheat down to [ __ ] dust oops
understand me but I come I get about 6
o'clock
wait a midday some scalpers for dinner
put some [ __ ] spinach and garlic
cloves in it I'm saying I'm trying
something awfully I'm trying to write
the I bought death check it out
hmm it's a beautiful [ __ ] eyeball
that's like 38 years to smoke I'm ready
for something like that that's a
beautiful [ __ ] eyeball right there
and then get your [ __ ] together that's
all I got that is savvy they got the
night off
no calls don't give a [ __ ]
tonight is dick tonight whatever
happened factory class Vegas what
happens in Santa Mike stays on Sammy you
wake up tomorrow morning you smoke a
bowl you go to church you do some
push-ups then you start [ __ ] my
[ __ ] yourself about the week I gonna
bump into a million dollars and it's a
lot of it ticket whatever I need to be
onion juice to bring me down off this
[ __ ] lost
oh yeah this is the real [ __ ] leap if
you reach to your city
the [ __ ] is that is only an animal bike
that I'm gonna get my slingshot
remember cats and
Manitou
well that said that's that I'll get my
scouts I gotta go watch TV I got [ __ ] to
do and people to see and I suggest you
do the same kind of circus spell to the
girls thank you very much for the hi for
sharing this eye with me you know I
appreciate all the ways I would listen I
wouldn't be doing this
mister that blood I just had enriched my
nose with that [ __ ] nose dang it the
heavy pot within the [ __ ] it is out of
them anyway you know I love you cannot
suffice
hit me up on Twitter I'll come back a
few hours you know me I smoked pot the
doctor don't scare they know boogie
ain't no bogeyman when you got reefer
you understand me you even think of that
you never seen the boogie man with a
fella I come in your room right now as
an adult for say listen I'm gonna shut
the lights off the boogie band school I
got recently boogie man can't do dick to
you when you got roof okay that's the
line that day uncle Joey loves you comes
up to stay black I got you [ __ ]
EBI of fight past right now have a good
time
trust me